now former republican senator
rick santorum well he just recently
departed fake news cnn after remarks he
made
at a young americas foundation event
about native americans the founding of
the country
where he said quote we birthed a nation
from nothing
yes there were native americans but
there isn't much native american culture
in american culture now despite santorum
admitting
multiple times that he misspoke and
trying to clarify his remarks on fake
news cnn
and what he was specifically talking
about that's not enough for the
left-wing outrage machine and that won't
cancel cultural
culture social warriors that pressured
fake news cnn
to cave to the mob and cut ties with
like the one guy that had a different
point of view
rick santorum but here's a question i
have for fake news cnn
have you made a decision yet about
jeffrey toobin's future
you know the guy caught on the zoom call
let's say enjoying himself a little too
much
i can mention a few other people that
are still working there too
here to respond senator rick santorum
senator how are you
um it's great to have you back i mean
all right thank you you made these
comments you say
it in an interview numerous times
that you misspoke and you explain what
you meant
why the firing
uh well i think you know you pointed to
some of it i mean that
that uh you know there's been a lot of
pressure from outside
uh there's been an effort you know i was
at cnn for four and a half years
and you know literally from the time i
started
uh there were groups out there calling
for me to be fired and so
in some respects i you know i give cnn
credit for holding on
four and a half years uh in spite of
some of the things i said defending
president trump and saying other things
you know about you know what
conservatives believe
and they gave me the opportunity to say
it uh in this case
you know it's it's a little
disappointing because as you mentioned
you know what i said was not at all
disparaging toward natives americans
what i was talking about is the founding
of the united states of america
and that uh and that you know that
native americans did not have a role in
the founding of our country now
the re you can you can say that's a bad
thing or a good thing or the way we
treated native americans or bad but
i was given to talk to a group of young
people talking about the founding
principles of religious liberty and how
important it was to
uh the immigrants who came here uh to
found this country and that then that
was an important value that was it was
imbued in our constitution uh so you
know we
one of the things i'm concerned about is
that you get in you you get uh
savaged by telling the truth and uh you
know i told the truth here and
uh you have other people who believe you
know don lemon came on right after my
interview and
said that native americans founded the
united states of america and
again i mean you're you're entitled to
your opinion you're not entitled to the
facts and that's where
i think we've gotten off kilter here a
little bit in america
well let me let me read exactly what i
said when you
when you said you misspoke and you said
it repeatedly again and again i noticed
i read the transcript
and then you went on to say i said
remember i said i said native americans
i said native americans didn't weren't
you know not a native american could uh
didn't affect
american culture anyways i meant the
american founding that's what we were
talking about the whole speech was on
the floor
no no what you said is no i was you're
right you said
they have had a huge impact these are
your words
right particularly in the west and many
other areas of our country
where they have had a huge impact on
american culture the opposite of what
they were claiming
you said and you said you misspoke and i
misspoke in this respect you apologized
for it
and now it raises the question in my
mind
about this is now the call this is now
the society we live in
i don't believe in boycott senator i've
never i never supported one i never will
i don't want bill maher fired i don't
want as a matter of fact
i defended him didn't want him fired
from abc
at the time and when joy reed was in
trouble
i was called by an nbc executive said
your public comments played a big role
in us
being able to keep her meaning her job
she wrote me a nice note
i didn't call i said people could make
mistakes
and move on but not anymore now it's oh
if you say something you can't even
revise and extend your remarks
apologize explain in more detail what
you meant nobody wants to hear it
and i'm sick of it to be honest
no this is i couldn't agree with you
more sean i've in many many cases
uh throughout my entire career people
have been called to be fired for saying
this and fire for saying this and i've
always defended their right and say you
know look people have a right to their
opinion and
uh and by the way cena has the right to
to fire me if they if they don't like
what i'm saying or what i'm doing they
have a right to fire me i have no
animus at all towards cnn like i said i
appreciate the opportunity they gave me
but i think it does show that the left
is is intolerant they they they're
worried i'm sure
that their viewership which is obviously
very left uh
was they were going to pay a price and
the intolerance of the left is really
the issue here and the cancel culture
that is flowing from it
and i i hear from a lot of liberals in
fact many cnn contributors who talk to
me afterwards
who are very very concerned about you
know the the canceled culture that's
that's now hitting them at cnn well
there's like a
kaylee mcadamy and then jeff lords fired
and you're fired
you know they really don't want
conservative views there now
i could say and i can name names here
there are plenty of people
on this channel i disagree with
completely
they don't even particularly like my
opinion we really have
a diversity of views which is i think
the right way to do it
um and my question is were you given any
reason for the firing to jeff
zucker you know did he talk to you about
it
uh you know what what i do know is that
as i said
are you ducking that question did you
talk to jeff zucker
i i didn't no i have not i've not talked
to jeff and so now
that several groups paid groups that
have uh have been trying to get me fired
for four years and
it's been a pretty persistent effort on
social media
you know there is an option for people
if you don't like what you're watching
if you don't like what you're listening
to on the radio if you don't like what
you're reading
you can turn it off you don't have to
watch
you don't have to listen how about we
really live up to the idea of of the
free and open exchange of ideas ideals
and opinions
even ones we hate and vehemently
disagree with
that's the america that i would prefer
even
everyone acts like they're offended at
everything and i'm not sure i believe
this faint outrage all the time well uh
i assume the application's in a fox or
no
uh well i'll just uh take a little time
off to uh
to regroup here a little bit and see
what see what opportunities come my way
but
let me just thank you for the
opportunity to come on and talk you're
you've always been a good friend i
appreciate that
all right we wish you the best and when
we come back hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else